>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> Nancy Groce: Hello it's --
my name is Nancy Groce
and its June 6, 2017.
And I'm here with Burt Feintuch
to talk about his career
and his experiences as a folklorist
and a scholar and a musician.
And first of all thanks
so much for joining us.
>> Burt Feintuch: My pleasure.
I was flattered that you invited me.
>> Nancy Groce: Yeah, and you're
here for a Batten lecture,
which will be given tomorrow.
>> Burt Feintuch: Right, mm-hmm.
>> Nancy Groce: Talking
about New Orleans and -
>> Burt Feintuch: And this
idea of cultural integrity
that I've been talking about lately.
>> Nancy Groce: So I understand
that your very generously going
to have some of your collections
come here to the library,
so we wanted to just talk to you
about how these collections came
to be and how you came to
be a folklorist and very -
kind of just an overview.
So, do you want to start with, did
you start off to be a folklorist
or a musician or where
did you grow up?
>> Burt Feintuch: I grew up mostly
in the suburbs of Philadelphia.
I grew up in Flutatown.
>> Nancy Groce: Flutatown.
>> Burt Feintuch: That's
in Pennsylvania.
Yeah I was born in Jersey City
which my mother concealed
from me for years.
>> Nancy Groce: And
what year was that?
>> Burt Feintuch: That was 1949.
I lived for the first several years
of my life in Rutherford, New Jersey
and then my father's
business from work,
took him to the Philadelphia
area, and we moved.
And how I became a folklorist?
>> Nancy Groce: Yeah.
>> Burt Feintuch: Well
I have a number of ways
of answering that question.
One is that I would say that when
I was 13 the mother of a friend
of mine took the two of us
to hear the Kingston Trio
at Princeton University.
And then retrospect and
that just fired me up.
In retrospect I think
it may have been more
that it was maybe the first
life music I'd ever encountered
or live music on stage
that I'd ever encountered,
but something really excited me.
And then I think inexplicably my
mother took me to see Pete Seeger
after that at the Academy
of Music in Philadelphia,
which really fired me up
and you know Bob Campbell has
written something about being taken
to hear Pete Seeger young
and how things were never
quite the same after that.
And I think that was true
for me, and so this was
of course during the great
folk song revival of the 60's.
And it meant that I got active in
the folk song club in high school
and all this sort of stuff.
>> Nancy Groce: Were
you a singer or -
>> Burt Feintuch: I was mostly
trying to play guitar and banjo
in those days, in those days.
And then I went on to
college at Penn State
where Sam Bayard was still teaching.
>> Nancy Groce: Oh really?
>> Burt Feintuch: Samuel
Preston Bayard, yeah.
>> Nancy Groce: So did
you study with him?
>> Burt Feintuch: I did, yeah.
Three or four courses and he had
studied with George Lyman Kittredge.
He had published one of the
first significant collections
of instrumental folk music
of fiddle and fife tunes
from southeastern Pennsylvania.
And it was a great old character.
I also had a course
from Bruce Rosenberg
who was there very briefly.
>> Nancy Groce: He must
have been quite young -
>> Burt Feintuch: I
think he was quite young.
I never really got to know him.
He was going through some personal
difficulties and was barely around.
>> Nancy Groce: Was
this in Harrisburg?
>> Burt Feintuch: No,
this was in State College.
>> Nancy Groce: Oh in
State College, oh okay.
>> Burt Feintuch: And I was
an American Studies major
but taking all the folklore courses
I could and became dimly aware
that there was such a thing as
a graduate degree in folklore.
>> Nancy Groce: What was
Bayard like as a professor?
>> Burt Feintuch: He
was a great character.
He seemed like an old guy then.
In retrospect I'm not
really sure how old he was,
but he had that kind
antiquarian feel about him.
He - what I think everyone remembers
about Sam Bayard is
that he used snuff.
That as he snorted,
he sniffed snuff.
And he had a collection
of antique snuff boxes.
And so he would come to
class and in the middle
of class he'd be dipping snuff,
or whatever the expression is;
I don't know what it is when you
inhale it as opposed to tuck it in.
But - and everybody would be
watching to see what sort of horn
or silver or whatever snuff box he
would pull out of his coat pocket.
And when he finished teaching
there was a fine powder
on the floor around him.
And you also knew that you'd
made it in his estimation
if he offered you a pinch of snuff,
which eventually he did for me.
It burned like crazy,
that's what I remember.
But he was very much
of an era, you know?
I think I had some sort of
general folklore class from him
where he used the croppy book,
the Science of Folklore,
from the 1930's.
I had an I think Folk Song and
Ballad or maybe just ballad class
with him where we basically
worked our way
through the Albert Freedman book
with him talking about
each of the texts.
He was also one of those
people of that generation
who had just this deep
knowledge of the material itself.
You know years later I
sent him some recordings
of some instrumental music
from the northeast of England,
I sent him some tune book copies
too, and he was able to talk
about the tune histories of all
that sort of stuff, you know?
He had that remarkable
kind of knowledge
that I think most of
us no longer have.
And he was you know,
encouraging about the idea
of studying folklore as well.
I also got to know Saul Brody
in those days, who was either in
or had finished I guess the
graduate program at Penn.
I guess he hadn't finished
his dissertation, which -
>> Nancy Groce: I think that
took a little bit longer.
>> Burt Feintuch: That
took a while, yeah.
But I lived in a house that had been
off campus, that had been claimed
by people who were involved
with what was called the
Penn State Folklore Society,
but was really a folk song society
sponsoring concerts and things.
And Saul used to come and stay
there when he was around town,
so learn some things about
the field from him as well.
Really I had no idea what
I was getting into honestly
between Sam's terrific but quite
old fashioned way and that sort
of generalities from Saul.
And in fact, sometimes these days I
tell people that I think it's likely
that I would have become a
musicologist if I'd known there was
such a field back then,
but I really didn't.
Because I went into the field,
you know because of a passion
for traditional music,
for vernacular music.
And it seemed like that was
the way to go in those days,
I'm not sure it is anymore.
>> Nancy Groce: So you
did an undergraduate at -
>> Burt Feintuch: At Penn State -
>> Nancy Groce: And then
where did you go next?
>> Burt Feintuch: University of
Pennsylvania for my Master's and PhD
in folklore and folk life.
>> Nancy Groce: And so - and
who were your professors there?
>> Burt Feintuch: Those days it
was Kenny Goldstein, Don Yoder,
Dan Benimos, Kenny and Dan,
Tris Koffin were the sort
of core of that program.
There was a guy named Tom Burns,
I don't know if that name
means anything to you.
Tom eventually sort
of left the field.
I went through that program
really quickly; you know I went
through from entering to
finishing my PhD in four years.
Barbara KG came in the year
that I was basically not there,
writing my dissertation,
so I never really got
to know her in that context.
I think that's who was there then.
I also did some course work with Ray
Birdwhistle out of the department
and someone in anthropology as well.
>> Nancy Groce: And
what did you write on?
What were you studying?
>> Burt Feintuch: I
wrote a dissertation
about a traditional fiddler
from southeast Pennsylvania,
his name was Earl Zeigler or Earl
Haffler actually, it's complicated
but Pop Haffler who was known as
sort of old time fiddle circles
and actually had a connection to
Alan Jabber and to Henry Glassy,
when Henry was state folklorist.
I didn't know Henry in
those days before my time,
he had recorded Pop Haffler for
whatever sort of work he was doing.
Alan had visited him either
through library or NEA
or something at some point.
>> Nancy Groce: Were you
playing fiddle at this time?
>> Burt Feintuch: I started
playing the fiddle a year or two
into graduate school; so yes.
>> Nancy Groce: Because you're
quite well known as a fiddler.
>> Burt Feintuch: I'm
flattered; thanks.
>> Nancy Groce: Yeah, and when
you were collecting from him,
were you playing fiddle
with him or were you -
>> Burt Feintuch: To some extent
and he was an elderly man.
He was a taxidermist and I
spent a year visiting him.
He lived in a small town not too
far - I never lived in Philadelphia.
When I was in graduate school in
Philly, I lived out in Bucks County,
commuted an hour, hour and a half
in because my then wife was teaching
in that area and it just made sense.
So I was living in a
place called Lahaska,
Pennsylvania between New Hope and
Doylestown, if that means anything
to you; if you know
that part of the world.
And Pop Haffer lived in a town
about half an hour away
called Quaker Town.
And it was just a great
Pennsylvania name, isn't it?
And he had a son who was older
than I was, who was a fiddle player
as well and we had more in common
in terms of repertoire than Pop,
who had become kind of an attraction
in old fiddlers picnics and things
in that part of Pennsylvania.
At that point there
weren't many people known
who could sort of fit that bill.
The old traditional musician.
>> Nancy Groce: And
playing regional repertoire?
>> Burt Feintuch: Yeah.
You know it's been so long since
I've listened to any of that
or thought about it, I can't
really talk much about it anymore.
I think my interest has always been
more in sort of understanding kind
of why people make music and how
people make music and how it fits
in their lives then it
is in repertoire itself.
So, I spent pretty much a
year visiting and interviewing
and traveling around
a little bit with him.
His wife died in that time and
he went into a deep depression
and stopped playing and you
know I happened to be with him
when he picked it up again, which
was an emotional moment for him.
It was a terrific experience.
It was also a dissertation
that was very much influenced
by all the performance theory
stuff that was happening
in those days for better or worse.
>> Nancy Groce: We've
recovered from the field but -
>> Burt Feintuch: Yeah,
but it's sort
of not the dissertation
I would write now.
>> Nancy Groce: And you were also
doing some collecting in Kentucky
and Tennessee early
in your career, right?
>> Burt Feintuch: A
little bit later.
What happened was in the year that
I was finishing - when I was at Penn
which was kind of the burgeoning
periods I think for that program.
Although I think they kind of
fooled us in that they made us think
that it was a better
established program
and better established
discipline than it really was,
which I think is part of
the job they had to do.
>> Nancy Groce: This would be
like in the mid to late 70's?
>> Burt Feintuch: This
was '71 to '75.
And you know the new perspective
stuff had just come out -
>> Nancy Groce: So you were all
sure you'd have careers and -
>> Burt Feintuch: Yeah, in fact
they used to say that everyone
who finished the degree there and
wanted an academic job got one.
>> Nancy Groce: Penn was certainly
the leading proponent at that point.
>> Burt Feintuch: The year that I
was finishing that didn't happen.
The bottom kind of fell out
and people weren't getting jobs
and it was a difficult
and frustrating time.
At the very last moment really
I learned about an opening
at Western Kentucky University,
which I think I learned about that
in you know April or May, very late.
And it was because
Mary Clark, of Mary
and Kenneth Clark, do
you know those names?
>> Nancy Groce: Yes.
>> Burt Feintuch: Had announced
her retirement I think late.
And I applied for and got that job.
So that took me to Bowling Green,
Kentucky Western Kentucky
University in the summer of 1975.
Where there was a great
archive of a lot
of old film music among
lots of other things.
Lynwood Montell had
been there for years;
DK Willis had been there
before he went to UCLA.
>> Nancy Groce: I'd forgotten that.
>> Burt Feintuch: Yeah, this was
before - DK was before my time.
But there were terrific recordings
of very archaic local fiddle music
that in many cases were done by
DK with Archie Green visiting.
Some Ed Conn and it was often, I
think Lynwood who was sort of from
that part of the country or not
far from that part of Kentucky.
I think it was Lynwood
who led them to some
of these people whom he'd known just
by virtue of having grown up there.
And I kind of got very
interested in that.
And I also early on met a fellow,
a wonderful fiddle player
who's become kind of legend
in old time fiddle revival,
a guy named Bruce Green.
I don't know if that name
means anything to you?
Bruce was from New
Jersey, very bright guy
who had gotten very interested
in archaic Kentucky fiddle music
and had gone to Western Kentucky
as an English major with the idea
that he might be able to do some
visiting and field research.
And he had done a wonderful job of
sort of turning up very old players
who had played a repertoire that
you just didn't hear any place else.
>> Nancy Groce: Very
regional repertoire?
>> Burt Feintuch: Yeah
very regional; yeah.
And it found a home recordings
and things of this sort.
And was an incredibly talent, almost
mimic of some of those players
that he really kind of got that.
You know many of us are
more kind of interpreters.
He was really kind of
able to replicate things.
And he used to - by that time
he had graduated, was there part
of the year and picking
apples in Vermont
to support himself
the rest of the year.
This really sounds like it's
certainly - but I was lucky enough
that he introduced me to some of
the old time musicians that he knew.
We got an early NEA folk arts grant
together to produce a double album
of both instrumental and vocal music
from that south central Kentucky
area and some of that was
from the archive, and some of
that was recordings that I did
with the folk like
center, borrowed -
>> Nancy Groce: From
the Library of Congress?
>> Burt Feintuch: Yeah from
the Library of Congress.
And it was one of the early NEA
grants to do a sound recording.
Yeah and then he ended up
moving out of the area,
moving to North Carolina.
I haven't seen him for years,
but he's sort of remained kind
of shadow legendary
figure for that kind
of old repertoire,
to some extent; yeah.
So that's really what got me
interested in both playing
and learning something of the
music from that part of the world.
In those days western was a
master's program in folklore
and just getting interested
in developing strengths
in the public sector, so it
was a pretty exciting time
to get there, to be part of that.
>> Nancy Groce: Can you talk a
little bit about public sector
because that's really when
public sector folklore started
to take off, right?
>> Burt Feintuch: Well I
guess one of the times; yeah.
>> Yeah, when I got there in '75,
I'm trying to remember
this, cloudy history.
There was a student
- a recent graduate
of the program named Linda White
I think who had gotten a job
as I think it was State
Folklorist in Tennessee.
It was very early, before Roby
Cogswell who you would know I think.
And there was a lot of sort
of excitement in the program
about the possibility of
helping students think
about careers in that direction.
One of the first experiences I had
with student, was I think it was
in the summer when I had arrived,
before I started teaching,
I sat in on a master's
thesis defense
by a young student named
Peggy Bulcher, for instance.
And of course we know
that history as well.
I guess she was coming up from
Florida at that point and working;
so there were - and I also was
on the thesis committee again I
think before I even started teaching
of a guy named George Reynolds
who was working for Fox Fire.
So there was a little bit of,
sort of direction developing
where students were getting their
masters degrees and moving off
into more public or
applied kinds of work.
And we began talking about
what can we do to help that
and to encourage it and work to
develop some internships and work
to develop some courses
and actually work
to develop what was called
historic preservation option.
I think which was a non-thesis
option for the master's degree.
We had people writing pretty
serious masters theses,
but we came up with
this more courses -
and some of those students actually
went into historic preservation.
But it was also a way to
begin to move into more public
or applied kinds of work
through internships,
through their own ingenuity.
And also in '85 I organized the
conference that became the book,
the Conservation of Culture,
which was published in '88.
So that was one of the first
big public folklore conferences.
There'd been Bob Byington
did something
in Pittsburgh years earlier that
people talked about quite a lot.
And we did a smaller one either the
late 70's or early 80's at Western.
And then '85 did one
that was quite a big one.
And that led, the library's
cultural conservation report
that Ormond Loomis I guess had
kind of led - had been published.
So that there was a lot of this
conversation going on in lots
of places by then, but we had this
conference that had stellar line
up of people who are
committed to the idea of what
in those days was called
cultural conservation.
>> Nancy Groce: Are you in touch
with Max Hall NEA quite a bit?
>> Burt Feintuch: Mm-hmm, and we
had Archie there to give a keynote,
Archie Green came to give a
keynote and Alan Jabbour was there
and that led to that book which for
a while was probably you know one
of the main texts for people
interested in you know reading
about public folklore anyway.
>> Nancy Groce: Did you
write it or did you -
>> Burt Feintuch: No it was edited.
It was based on that conference,
on the papers from that conference.
I had an editor from the
University Press of Kentucky,
which is one of those consortium
presses who had been sort of curious
about the possibility of publishing
this, come down to the conference
and he left very excited
about the possibility.
>> Nancy Groce: That
was really classic book;
it's still in print, isn't it?
>> No.
No, I think that there's
an online version available
through the Kentucky Press although
I don't actually know for sure.
There was a brief moment where it
looked like another press wanted
to reissue it and I had the
copyright reverted to me,
or whatever the term is for
that and then that fell through.
It suddenly was one of those times
when all the university
presses were saying "Oh God,
we're in trouble now;
what can we do"?
We only need to publish bestselling
fiction and cook books you know?
So, it never happened.
>> Nancy Groce: So how long
were you at Western Kentucky?
>> Burt Feintuch: I
was there for 13 years.
I was there from '75 to '88.
>> Nancy Groce: And then
you got lured away by -
>> Burt Feintuch: No then I
worked hard to find another job.
I - there was a lot I really
loved about being at Western.
I wasn't wild about - my then wife
and I weren't wild about the idea
of having children grow
up there at that point.
And a funny way the longer
I was there the less it felt
like home I think too, sort
of culturally you know?
It was a very religiously
conservative place.
It was an hour or so from Nashville;
this is before Nashville kind
of had the renaissance
that it's gone through.
It felt kind of remote and again, we
weren't so comfortable with the idea
of having kids grow up in a
place where they were fighting
about the Ten Commandments
on the wall
of classrooms and things
of that sort.
So I actually started
looking for a job and I had -
I had gotten involved with the
Kentucky Humanities Council,
the state council there and in
fact had ended up chairing it
in what turned out to be a
sort of challenging year.
And our executive director
resigned to take another job.
And also a really rewarding year.
We had an early award from
excellence from the NEH,
which was then recognized in
certain councils for excellence.
And as I was looking for other
kinds of jobs I started applying
for humanities and directorships and
ended up in New Hampshire in '88.
>> Nancy Groce: So you
went to New Hampshire as -
>> Burt Feintuch: As Director
of the Center of Humanities.
Not really as a folklorist, in fact
they weren't quite sure I think what
to do with me as a folklorist.
There had been someone
in the English Department
who had taught a little bit
of folklore and literature
but was a literary scholar
and no training in folklore
or any allied field at all.
And there was also a name that you
probably know, Linda Morley living
in Manchester, New Hampshire
who had done some work
as a state folklorist before
my time, was doing a little bit
of teaching for the University
for the English Department.
And although I've never really asked
I think what happened is some higher
administrator said "Okay
we're going to hire this guy,
where are we going
to put a folklorist"?
And they said, "Let's
put him in English"
because at least the word
shows up occasionally
in the catalog or something there.
In some ways in retrospect I think
I would have done just as well
or maybe better in Anthropology.
I mean I'm very happy in English
and my colleagues are great
and they're very supportive
and interested in what I do,
but really that was in a
certain sense a turning point
in my career as an academic.
You know I continued to write and do
the research that I do in the field,
but that's not really why I'm there.
I teach one course a year.
I've been teaching, early on I
taught some folklore you know,
Introduction to Folklore courses
and I was teaching
some graduate students.
I eventually decided I didn't want
to teach graduate students anymore,
although I taught mostly
grad students
at the masters level at Western.
Because I just didn't really enjoy
teaching English Lit grad students
who wanted things from me that
I was interested in giving them.
And you know with my much more kind
of ethnographic orientation
in that era anyhow.
And now in recent years I've been,
for a while I was teaching a course
that I called The Ethnography
of Music,
which was a fieldwork
class basically.
And the last couple of years
I've taught an American Roots
music class.
My classes are all cross
listed by anthropology as well.
But I'm really there directing
this research center, research
and programming center
in the humanities.
>> Nancy Groce: But in your
spare time you continue
to do research and fieldwork?
>> Burt Feintuch: Sure, yeah.
I love to do that and I certainly
have continued to do that.
>> Nancy Groce: So will your
next big research project
after leaving Western
Kentucky, I always think of you
about that time starting
to work in North Umberland,
but maybe that was
a little bit later.
>> Burt Feintuch: Yeah
actually I should tell you this,
how are we doing on time?
>> Nancy Groce: We're doing fine.
>> Burt Feintuch: I should tell
you this little bit too I guess,
back to why I chose
to be a folklorist.
In 1969 in my junior year as an
undergraduate I studied abroad
at the University of Durham
in the Northeast of England.
And it was a brand new program
then and I was vaguely aware
that there was something akin to
the US folk song revival happening
in the UK, but didn't
know much about it.
In fact, I remember Michael Cooney,
if you remember - he
told me about that.
And so I got there and I
asked one of the faculty
where I might go hear some music.
And he said "Go to New Castle",
which was about 20 minutes away
on the train on a Thursday night and
go to this pub called the Bridge,
which turned out to be one of the
legendary clubs in the folk revival
in England, sort of powerful
commitment to regional music there,
to local music in New Castle
as then the sort of main city
of the North Umberland region,
although technically
now it's not part
of the county of North Umberland.
It had a huge history, industrial
history and a lot of music call
and a lot of local song
and also a lot of -
and also the whole north Umbrian
piping tradition, the small pipe,
a distinctive instrument from that
part of the world, to manuscripts
and libraries dating back
to the 1660's and so forth.
And I just stumbled on
this and although had sort
of split my time listening half to
the New Lost City Ramblers and half
to James Brown as an undergraduate,
I didn't really get the idea
fully I think until I was there
that music is as local
as it was there.
You know as people purveyed it as
and you know you could hear people
play a tune named for a street
that you'd walk down as you went
to the train station to go back
to where you were living.
And that really made a
powerful impact on me as well,
I think intellectually and
in my interest and also
because the musicians are
essentially doing tune scholarship.
You know helped me think about -
>> Nancy Groce: It's Allister
Anderson was probably there
at the time -
>> Burt Feintuch: The
group the High Level -
>> Nancy Groce: Oh yeah -
>> Burt Feintuch: Colin Ross who
was one of the first fiddle players
in the revival there after Dave
Swarbuck, yeah so at some point
in Kentucky some years
later I got the idea
that maybe I could write an
article about the revival
of the North Umbrian small pipes,
and managed to raise some money
to go do a summer of field work.
This would have been
around '85 I think.
And that just sort of spun
out of control in a good way
in that I kept raising money and
kept going back sort of interviewing
and recording everything I could.
I was there for years,
did some - a few articles
about the revival there,
eventually produced Folkways CD,
a Smithsonian Folkways of Music -
>> Nancy Groce: The
North Umberland Grant -
>> Burt Feintuch: Yeah.
>> Nancy Groce: Which is a great CD.
>> Burt Feintuch: Thanks, thanks.
It was a lot of fun to do.
And that is one of the largest
sort of piles of recordings I have
that will be part of
the contribution.
>> Nancy Groce: And who were
you recording at that point?
Were you recording at the Bridge
or were you going out and doing -
>> Burt Feintuch: No the Bridge was
sort of - it hadn't stopped then
but it had stopped
being what it had been.
It had become more
of a generic club.
The people who had gotten it going
weren't really going there anymore,
so I was very interested
first in the history
of the small pipes
and of the revival.
And talking to -- here
was older generation sort
of gentlemen had been involved in
that, a lot of talk with Colin Ross
who was the first sort of -
one of the first people to -
of a later generation to make the
instrument and make it available
and David Burley who was
probably the first who made -
David sort of made the Chevy
of the North Umberland
small pipes made a lot
of them on the assembly line.
>> Nancy Groce: People had
stopped making that instrument.
>> Burt Feintuch: You could
barely get your hands on a set
if you wanted them and then
suddenly they were available again.
And some people said the answer
to why there's a revival is
you can buy the pipes again.
I think more complicated, but
I was going back quite a lot -
doing a lot of recording,
several hundred hours
I think of recordings -
>> Nancy Groce: Were you
doing just with Umberland,
were you across the border at all?
>> Burt Feintuch: Some, well not in
Scotland, I never got to Scotland.
When you say cross the border
I think Durham, to the south.
Yeah. And that's probably a lot
of academics of the great book
that they didn't write, that's mine.
There's a lot of material there
and you know and an assortment
of publications but the
book never got written.
And part never got written
because I got the job offer at UNH,
at the University of New Hampshire.
That same year I had an NEH
fellowship offered to me and had
to not take the fellowship
so as to take the job at UNH.
UNH, the search had failed the year
before and they're very anxious
to get someone to get it started so
they wouldn't let me wait a year.
In those days NEH wouldn't
let you defer either.
So, I think I went back to
North Umberland once or twice
in the early years at UNH,
but it kind of lost momentum
and you know eventually I went to
Cape Brenton too and that was kind
of bad news for North Umberland.
>> Nancy Groce: Let's
talk about that
because in the last 20 years it's
really been a lot in Cape Brenton.
So when did you make
that switch and being
in New Hampshire must have helped -
>> Burt Feintuch: It
certainly helps logistically.
You know this goes back to
me as a musician actually.
I had started paying the fiddle as
an old time fiddle player in part
because a guy who you also knew
name Jerry Milnes who was at Augusta
and West Virginia, who was -
when I was in graduate school was
around Philadelphia working
as an industrial model maker
and playing old time music
with a bunch of friends.
And I ran into him once and
mentioned the fact that I loved
to fiddle and he said "I'll
give you some lessons".
So, I went to him maybe
half a dozen times
and that really got me started,
but that was my only almost sort
of official education in playing.
The rest was by ear and by
trial and error, a lot of error.
And I got to New Hampshire in
'88 and couldn't find anyone
who played the music I played.
>> Nancy Groce: Which
was mostly southern -
>> Burt Feintuch: Southern
old time music
because that's what I'd
been doing in Kentucky.
And so I had to kind of retool
to play for contra dances,
which was playing a lot of
some New England repertoire
and you know the kind of mish
mash of stuff that's played there,
a lot of Irish music and these days
if you're going to go to a session
where I live you're probably
going to play Irish music,
which led me to listen a little
bit to Cape Breton music,
which I think I would have dismissed
as not very interesting when I was
in Kentucky because my
aesthetic was so different.
But I thought wow, this is kind of
an interesting thing and for reasons
that I don't' fully you know,
remember decided to go spend a week
at a fiddle event in Cape Breton.
I think this was 1997.
One of these things where you
sit at the feet of masters.
And it was also great that you could
drive there of course as opposed
to fly to the Northeast of England.
But it was a marvelous
experience in part because I got
to know these wonderful players,
Buddy McMaster, Ken
Inbeton and others.
And I think my sort of folklore
self, clicked in as well as soon
as I realized that the music was
so locked into community there too.
It wasn't just going to something
where people taught
you and went home.
They left to play for
a dance or something.
And so you know the folklore
made me sort of the outlier
that first year there because all
the students at this thing would say
"Where are we going to get together
to play tunes with each other"
and I'd say "I'm going
to a dance", you know?
And it just kind of blew me away
how vital the tradition was there
compared to anything I'd known.
And so I started setting
up interviews
and started going back
and kept going back.
And you know was lucky
enough to do a couple
of the Smithsonian folkways
projects and to do some writing.
And eventually got the idea
to do a book with my friend
and collaborator Gary
Sampson a photographer,
who had been the official
photographer
at the University of New Hampshire.
But had moved on to
teach photography
at the New Hampshire Institute
of Arts in Manchester.
When he was still at UNH,
UNH sent him to Cape Breton
to do some photographs of me at
work for the university's magazine.
>> Nancy Groce: Just to make
sure you were actually working?
>> Burt Feintuch: And he
had been there years ago
on some other assignment
and it turned
out you know we discovered
we both loved the place.
>> Nancy Groce: And this is
mostly the Gaelic tradition
of Cape Breton or also in French?
>> Burt Feintuch: No, it's -
my work has been pretty largely
in what people would say
is the Gaelic community,
although they don't by and
large speak Gaelic anymore.
I know people in the
French community as well
and the Scottish music or what used
to be called the Cape Breton
Scottish violin music before they
started just saying Cape Breton.
So dominant there that
you hear a lot
of Francophones playing the music
and people playing the music
to the Francophone community,
has been working hard
to sort of revitalize things.
And there is a history of you know,
publishing song books and things
of that sort too, that I don't'
know all that much about.
But the kind of cultural
boundaries are really porous there.
>> Nancy Groce: You were there
just when Cape Breton music sort
of exploded on the world stage.
>> Burt Feintuch: Yeah or
maybe just slightly afterwards
when I was there Natalie McMaster
and Ashley McIsaac the two people
who kind of caused that
explosion were riding very high.
Natalie continues to ride
pretty high and Ashley kind
of burned out a little bit.
But these were two young people
with strong family traditions
of fiddle playing, lessons
from some of the same people,
who became immensely popular
first in Canada and beyond.
Ashely had done a CD that mixed
traditional fiddle music with the -
a lot of very in your face
rock and roll that was -
that went whatever it was
platinum or something.
>> Nancy Groce: And in Britain
also, it did well in Brittan.
>> Burt Feintuch: I don't know
that, but I'm not surprised.
He'd be playing at a dance in a
little community, there'd be a line
down the street of teenage
girls wanting to see it;
it was a great scene to
hear this fiddle player
who is a very traditional
style fiddle player or can be.
And Natalie had worked to create a
kind of act that made the music work
for all kinds of audiences but
not so much the hard rock stuff
that Ashley was doing,
and she's really endured.
So, yeah so it was very big
then across Canada and beyond.
>> Nancy Groce: And
Celtic colors started -
>> Burt Feintuch: A few years later.
The book that I started talking
about which was called In The Blood,
Cape Breton Conversations
on Culture.
The idea was to talk to people who
one way or another sort of engaged
with culture in their lives.
A lot of musicians would
also one of the founders
of Celtic Colors Festival Joella
Folds, who stepped away from it now,
but until recently was
really the force behind it.
>> Nancy Groce: I know
her from Scotland -
>> Burt Feintuch: Celtic
Connections - yeah I know she was -
she talks about being inspired
by that to start this festival
that would extend the short
season in Cape Breton,
the short tour season
so they do it in October
and it's been a huge success I
think and it's run very, very well.
>> Nancy Groce: So you're recording
- you say you're as interested
in the stories and how people
use music as with the music.
But the In the Blood
Book, which we have here,
it has a lot of interesting
interviews with people;
how did you decide who to
interview for that field work?
>> Burt Feintuch: I think you
- I think what I did was sort
of follow my passion
more than map anything
out that had any kind of logic.
I knew that I wanted
to go beyond musicians.
I knew there were musicians
that I really wanted to talk
to who I think needed to be on
the record in terms of talking
about life and their stories
as much as their music,
which was already on the record.
But I also wanted to talk
to people who were involved
with language revival, with
the development of festivals
and some other sorts of things too.
I talked to someone who is
a publisher of tune books,
whose tune books have had a
very powerful impact on the -
>> Nancy Groce: Whose -
>> Burt Feintuch: Paul Cranford.
>> Nancy Groce: Is he
the lighthouse keeper?
>> Burt Feintuch: Yeah.
Retired from that now.
Yeah I mean - one thing I realized
in North Umberland was that some
of the early tune books really
kind of established a repertoire.
And I don't think that's so true in
Cape Breton but it's in part true
and a lot of that is Paul's work.
>> Nancy Groce: And it's
during Holland too -
>> Burt Feintuch: During Holland,
yeah who I felt very
lucky to get to know.
>> Nancy Groce: Yeah
he's a lovely guy.
>> Burt Feintuch: Yeah and
just a brilliant musician.
>> Nancy Groce: And Brenda
Stubbord is up there also.
>> Burt Feintuch: Yeah I know
Brenda well, I haven't seen her
for a while, but know her well.
Yeah. We went to - I interviewed
Brenda and we went to -
Gary was with me and we went to do a
photograph of her and she was living
in a place called Florence
then in Cape Breton.
And Gary had lights with him,
which he didn't normally have
but he plugged some lights
in and set up the shot
and tripped the shutter and the
power went out all over town.
It turns out she is a locally
celebrated tune composer
to which kept saying she was going
to write a tune called
"Burt's Power Surge".
She did write a tune
for me, different title.
>> Nancy Groce: Oh she did,
okay we'll have to get it.
Have you play that at some point.
>> Burt Feintuch: Yeah so Cape
Breton just kind of kept going.
This is about the 20th anniversary
of my starting to go to Cape Breton
and for a while I was going
three or four times a year.
You know any time I could, it's
about a 700 mile or so drive
from my house, but
not a bad drive at all
and I really can't remember the
number of times that I've done that.
>> Nancy Groce: So do you feel
part of that community now?
>> Burt Feintuch: I
hadn't gone for a couple
of years and went back last June.
I was asked to be on the board
of the Celtic Music Interpretive
Center that's on the honorary board.
And they were having a tenth year
anniversary and I went back for that
and felt very moved
by how connected.
I felt two people and how
people were reciprocal and one
of the biggest honors I think of
my career was - so it was a dinner
and sort of celebration
for the tenth anniversary
and then there was a concert
in the hall next to the center.
One of the musicians who I
know fairly well got on stage
and thanked someone who was a big
donor who helped support the event
and thanked me and said that what I
had done was archive their culture,
which is not exactly
how I would say it
but it was something
I found really moving.
And I'm hoping at some point that
those recordings will also end
up in a Cape Breton institution
along with coming here
and have talked to the interpretive
center and to special collections
at Cape Breton University
about that.
>> Nancy Groce: What
are you working on now,
are you doing Cape
Breton stuff or are you -
>> Burt Feintuch: I don't think I'll
ever stop doing Cape Breton stuff,
although I don't have
anything particular going on.
I have an article that will be
a chapter in a book in progress.
A book that's being edited by
a couple of Jeff Titans friends
and students not quite a fetch
rift but something to recognize him
about music and sustainability.
>> Nancy Groce: Much
like a fetch rift -
>> Burt Feintuch: It's not
going to be identified as such
but where I talk about Cape Breton
and New Orleans in the same breath
as I am going to do here.
After Gary and I did the Cape Breton
book we said this is really a lot
of fun and it was kind of - sort
of targeted in a more focused way
than a lot of my other
things have been.
Let's do these interviews, do
these photographs and do a book.
And we said let's try
something else.
We kind of know how to do this now,
let's do another one and I said,
"Let's go to New Orleans".
>> Nancy Groce: And why New Orleans?
>> Burt Feintuch: I had been
in New Orleans for something,
I think Juney, my partner
and I Juney Thomas
and I had gone maybe
for my birthday.
I haven't been there for
years, since I was a teenager.
And we went to hear one of the
musicians that's always been a kind
of musical hero, Walter
Wolfman Washington.
>> Nancy Groce: Oh really?
>> Burt Feintuch: Great sort of soul
and funk musician, just grabs me.
And we left and I said I'm
going to do something here,
and I thought for a while I'd like -
I wonder if I could
write his life history.
And then I thought I don't
know, I don't know him,
I don't know you know how
feasible a project that is.
But that led me to think
"Well Gary and I do know how
to do these interview and photograph
books, let's do one in New Orleans.
And Gary had never been to New
Orleans, and I thought to myself -
so I had this sort of deep
ethnographic engagement
with Cape Breton, can I do something
almost more like a journalist would,
that is sort of set some
parameters with the goal
of producing something and do it.
And so for me it was an
experiment really and we did it.
>> Nancy Groce: And
that resulted in -
>> Burt Feintuch: The book
Talking New Orleans Music,
which came out in 2015.
>> Nancy Groce: Was your
research done before
or after or during Katrina?
>> Burt Feintuch: After.
There's some conversation
about Katrina of course,
more or less depending
who I talked to.
It's interviews with 11 musicians,
actually one of whom is not really
in New Orleans as much a
musician as a producer,
a guy named Scott Billington;
I don't know if you know Scott.
Scott is now Vice President
for ANR for Rounder,
but he produced all the Rounder
recordings from Louisiana,
but from New Orleans
and a lot the Cajun
and Coast stuff they did
too starting the 80's.
So I knew Walter Wolfman
Washington's music thanks
to Scott's production.
And Scott was in those days
living in New Bridgeport,
Massachusetts half an hour from
me and had grown up in kind
of Boston Blues Revival scene,
a friend of Erica Brady's
our colleague.
And was actually a great interview
and kind of opened the door
to people like Erma Thomas for me.
>> Nancy Groce: Opened the door, did
he put you in touch with them or -
>> Burt Feintuch: He gave me
Erma's personal email address
and let me take it from there, yeah.
Yeah that to me, too is a thrill
because I've always loved her music
and it was hard to get
to her, not because -
just because of her
schedule and mine.
In fact Gary and I decided
to make one last trip
to shoot some more photos
and do a little bit more work
and I emailed her once again saying
"I'm coming, this is the last time,
would it be possible at
all to do an interview?
And remember I'm Scott's friend"
and wherever we switched plans
as we were flying to New
Orleans, I checked my email
and there was an email from
her saying call my manager.
Her manager is her husband you
know, and so I called and I said
"This is me" and "Erma
said she'd do an interview"
and you could tell they were sitting
watching television together.
And then her husband said, "Hey
did you say you'd do an interview
with some guy" and she
said, "Yeah I guess".
And he said, "When do you want
to come" and I said "When's good"
and he said, "When's good"?
And we set it up and
went and did it.
And it was really last minute
and as I said a thrill.
>> Nancy Groce: So are you -
>> Burt Feintuch: So
what am I doing now?
>> Nancy Groce: Or what's next?
>> Burt Feintuch: I'm doing what
I think is probably the last
of these books that I think of
somewhere between scholarship
and art books, thanks to
the photographic part of it.
We had such a good
time in New Orleans,
we said let's try another one and
let's try it sort of on this model.
You know can we do it
without spending the rest
of my life making these trips.
And so we're doing a book that
we're calling Creole Soul,
which is about [Inaudible].
Working both in Texas
and in Louisiana.
An actually started in Texas
and I'm really convinced
that the Texas part is more
interesting and more vital
than Louisiana part, a lot
of people don't know that.
Although there's a fine
book about Zytigo in Texas
by a guy named Roger Wood.
But what happened is a lot of Creole
people from South Louisiana moved
to East Texas for work, starting
in the early twentieth century
and in more urban environments,
some of the urban stuff you hear
in Zytigo now developed more in
Texas than it did in Louisiana,
came back to Louisiana, yeah.
So that's been a lot of fun and we
were there - we were in Louisiana
for a week or so in March.
And getting close I think
we have enough interviews.
We may go back to do
some more photographs.
>> Nancy Groce: You've done so much
field work and we've spent most
of this discussion so
far talking about that.
But could you talk a
little bit about what you --
you were the editor
of the American -
>> Burt Feintuch: The
Journal of American Folklore -
>> Nancy Groce: For a while right?
>> Burt Feintuch: From
1990 to 1995, yeah.
What do you want me to talk about?
>> Nancy Groce: That
can be an overview
of the field in a different way.
>> Burt Feintuch: Sure
of course it did.
That was - so that
started in my second year
at the University of New Hampshire.
>> Nancy Groce: And how
did - did you volunteer?
Did you volunteer or did
someone volunteer you for this?
>> Burt Feintuch: I think
it was that I was sort
of foolish enough to say yes.
Roger Abrahams asked me if
I would be interested in -
and Kenny Goldstein did -
>> Nancy Groce: So they
were both your professors -
>> Burt Feintuch: Roger
had not been my professor.
I knew Roger - I knew
Roger a little bit.
Roger came to Penn years later.
Of course Roger had gotten
his degree from Penn too,
but that was long gone
by the time I got there.
So it's funny, I don't remember
entirely how this happened
but I was sort of taken aback
to be asked if I'd be interested
in doing it and I think it was that
I had invited Roger to give a talk
at UNH in the early years.
I tried to bring some folklorists
in and that just went by the wayside
as my budget changed and so forth.
But we had Barbaga KG I remember
as well and I think maybe he asked.
And my sense is in those
days there was less interest
in being democratic
than there is now.
I mean it was in some ways, in some
ways it doesn't seem that long ago
and in some ways it was quite a long
time ago in terms of how we think
about how to do things openly
and fairly it seems to me.
So I was asked if I
would be interested.
Probably there were other
people asked too, I don't know.
And I went to my dean who in
those days was a very sort
of powerful figure at the university
and things were going
fairly well financial.
And he offered the
support that I would need
and I said, "Okay" and it happened.
Toward the end of my time I got
asked if I would be interested
in re-enlisting for five years
and I said no, and I realized
that my ego had said yes
and for the 1990-1995 term,
but my common sense
caught up with me during
that time - it was a lot of work.
But you know I think we did some
things that made a difference.
We did that key words issue,
the body [Inaudible] issue.
>> Nancy Groce: Was that the one
you worked on with Michael Taft?
>> Burt Feintuch: No this was the
one called Common Ground that led
to the Eight Words for the Study
of Expressive Culture book.
That was first a special issue
and in fact, the Illinois,
the press had to be convinced
that there was a reason
to do a book version because why
don't people just read the journal?
Yeah, and so that turned out to be
a pretty influential publication
and you know it was a
really interesting time.
For me I said early on that had I
know differently I might have become
an ethnomusicologist.
Started graduate school I
was astonished at the range
of interests other students had.
I thought we'd all be there
just talking about ballads
or something I guess, as having
been the student of Sam Bayard.
But here were these people
interested in myth and other forms
of narrative and all sorts of stuff.
I had very little idea of
the breadth of the field,
and of course this was
years later but working
in the journal too it
certainly exposed me to that
and you know interesting
and exciting ways.
And then it became hard work.
I was thinking about the other day,
this was the beginning
of email for instance.
We were doing things by
fax and mail and so forth
and I was worried it was
kind of transitional moment.
>> Nancy Groce: Amazingly
survived without emails
or computers when you started?
>> Burt Feintuch: Yes.
>> Nancy Groce: Did you -
you probably did your
dissertation on a typewriter?
>> Burt Feintuch: Well you paid
someone or convinced someone
to type it for you in those days but
it was done on a typewriter, sure.
>> Nancy Groce: And you are also
I should mention just as part
of the interview that you were -
was it in 2012 you became a fellow
of the American Folklore Society?
>> Burt Feintuch: I don't
remember what year it was,
but it was fairly recently, yeah.
>> Nancy Groce: That gives you more
status in the meetings immediately.
>> Burt Feintuch: I haven't noticed.
Nope, the fellows do a breakfast
for graduate students and they -
I think they find new fellows
who are the suckers who will get
up early in the morning and go sit
at a table with graduate students.
It's a nice event and the
fellows also do a reception
for graduate students.
>> Nancy Groce: That's true.
>> Burt Feintuch: The ones I've
been to have been very nice events.
>> Nancy Groce: And the membership
has expanded and broadened too.
>> Burt Feintuch: Well there's
some of us pushing for that,
it still needs to go
quite a ways I think,
but at least I think more
people understand why it should
as does the society itself
with its own membership.
>> Nancy Groce: Now what part
of your career have I not talked
about and not asked you about?
>> Burt Feintuch: Well one thing,
I don't know if I've mentioned this
as I've talked to Todd in the
library about field work material
that I'll be compiling and giving.
The first field work I actually
did was in British Columbia
in my first summer after my
first year in graduate school.
I got a grant that I
think channeled what was
in the Canadian folk music
society that this was a time
when Canada was thinking a lot
about multi-culturism and developing
that notion of a mosaic
of cultures rather
than the melting pot
metaphor we're using here.
And they're interested in having
someone do some fieldwork having
to do with bilingual
community in British Columbia,
how that happened I
don't really know.
It's where those funds came
from, why that decision was made.
But I was encourage by
Kenny I think and helped
in my proposal writing by Dan.
Wrote a proposal, got the
grants spent this summer.
I could have been just kind of
blindly looking for something to do
in British Columbia
but by luck ended
up in a failed finished
Utopian community on an island
between the northern
part of Vancouver Island
and the British Columbia
mainland, a place called Sointulla
which in Finnish means harmony,
which has been established
around 1900, by Finnish
immigrants from Western Canada
and the upper Midwest to the US.
Many of whom had been
agricultural people in Finland,
but ended up logging or mining and
doing things they found unpleasant.
And brought over a kind of fiery
socialist leader from Finland
who led them in creating a
community on this island,
which for a time the Canadian
government gave to them
and became kind of extra
territorial, not part of Canada.
It failed as a Utopian
community in part
because it wasn't suitable
for agriculture.
And people went back into
mostly fishing and some logging.
But at that point, this would have
been summer of 72, 500 people living
in this beautiful spot in a very
kind of rugged part of Canada
in those days, very
hard to get to there.
And in the summer men would
go out fishing, come back in
and somebody would
have a music party.
And I was there recording
music and talking to people
and did a little bit of writing
about that, so I have that material
as well and it was you know, an odd
thing because I don't speak Finnish.
And Alli Congess Miranda did a
little bit of translation for me
for something, I don't really
remember what some time after maybe
as I was writing my final report
for my grant or something,
but that was a marvelous
experience in beginning
to understand what field work was.
Again that was after a
year of graduate school.
>> Nancy Groce: Interesting.
Maybe Todd Harvey is
sitting in on this.
Is there any questions you have?
>> Todd Harvey: You talked
about using the Nagra recorder,
talk about other gear that
you favored [Inaudible].
>> Burt Feintuch: Yeah
I used all kinds of -
>> Nancy Groce: So we had a
question from Todd Harvey who is
on the side here, who is one of
our archivists and he wants -
he was curious about the gear
you use both in North Umberland
and in your other field
work collections?
You borrowed a nagra from
the library at one point.
>> Burt Feintuch: Yeah I was
very lucky in that you know
in those days this being
around '75, '76 the library,
the Folk Life Center had a
program lending out nagras and I -
Bruce Green and I had gotten
the grant to do that piece
that I had mentioned to you that
involves some new field recording.
And I asked if I could borrow
a machine and it so happened
that Carl Fleishauer
was lucky enough
to see [Inaudible] I think picking
one up some place that maybe someone
in Tennessee was using it.
It was going to be coming - it
was in the area and it worked
out that he could both drop one off
for me in Bowling Green, Kentucky
and also teach me how to use it.
And that was really my first
experience you know thinking
about recording well.
A little bit from Kenny.
When I'd gone to British
Columbia he'd loaned me one
of those little five inch Sony,
I forget what they were a little
five inch reel to reel recorders,
battery operated recorders
that Sony had out,
that was his own machine
and he had loaned me.
I had the nagra for a while
and a few other things
with it, not just that recording.
But of course it went back
to the library to my dismay.
And then of course what do you
do on a more limited budget
when you can't afford a nagra 4S
and convince the program at Western
to buy a couple of viewers -
>> Nancy Groce: Yeah.
>> Burt Feintuch: And use those
and then hire quality cassette
recording became possible, the -
was it Sony TCD5M, does
that sound right to you?
It was a little metal cassette
recorder that people we reusing
for at least broadcast
quality, so I had one of those.
>> Nancy Groce: You were using
it with two external mics?
>> Burt Feintuch: External
mics, yeah, I had some kind
of [Inaudible] in those days.
As I left there and went to New
Hampshire I acquired a dat recorder.
I did a little bit on mini disk too.
The North Umbrian stuff because
of issues of portability some
of that was done on that - the
Sony D5M or whatever it was
and then later a Walkman Pro I think
they were called, audio cassettes.
We've all seen these things if
we've been around long enough.
More recently I've done some one
bit recording on a Corg MR1000.
I don't know if you're
familiar with those here.
They never really caught
on very much,
but they're very high
quality recorders,
one that I bought for myself.
But traveling to - on airplanes
the bigger stuff is a bother,
and so I started using a Task M
DR40, which I despite actually.
And finally in recent years bought
a Zoom H5N or whatever it is,
which is to me a superior
machine, just easier to work
and less prone to screw ups.
I've kind of used a lot
of media over the years.
I still have the dat
recorder if I ever need
to play anything, assuming
it will play.
Although I had no problems
with dats.
I know they're notoriously -
>> Nancy Groce: Unstable.
>> Burt Feintuch: Difficult.
>> Nancy Groce: You've done most of
your field recording has been audio?
Or have you also done video?
>> Burt Feintuch: Very little video.
You know I recorded a - I
did a little bit of video
on Sony Portapack in my graduate
school days, which was a bulky black
and white thing that
recorded on reels
and I don't know what
happened to that material.
Speaking of not knowing whatever
When I got back from - I'm
jumping around, but when I got back
from studying abroad in England, all
charged up I got asked at Penn State
by the person who ran the so
called Artisan Lecture Series,
which was a very big
attraction for students
to help produce a folk festival
at Penn State and we brought in -
and the resources seemed unlimited,
you know in those days and I said,
"Let's bring in all these
people" and it ranged
from bringing the Balfa Brothers
and Mississippi Fred McDowell
to bringing big revival
acts like Joan Baez
and the High level ranters were flew
in from England and Al Anderson sort
of credits me with
getting his career started;
it was his first trip
to the US and in
that time I interviewed Fred
McDowell just because he was there
and I had this vague sort
of sense that's what you do,
and I don't know whatever
happened to that recording.
Likewise when I was in Durham
I - there was a local group
of young guys playing regional
music and I borrowed a recorder
and recorded them, one of those
people was Dave Richardson who went
on to Boys of - yeah,
who I've known for years.
I haven't seen for years; so in
a sense I was doing field work
in the dark and I don't
know what happened
to those several recordings.
>> Nancy Groce: Things turned out -
>> Burt Feintuch: Those
I don't think will.
>> Nancy Groce: Well we
can - this has been great.
Thank you so much for coming in.
>> Burt Feintuch: Thanks
for doing this.
>> Nancy Groce: We
might do a follow up.
We won't have a chance to
look at your material -
but for right now this has
been really interesting;
so thank you so much.
>> Burt Feintuch: Thank you.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.